why don't you run for office would you
vote for me yes I thought well I vote
for you on the but alone according to
you well yeah they get rid of Kim
Kardashian so glad that this next guest
actually one of the first guests I think
we have had on ladder with Crowder but
it was a while ago and we were new we
were still kind of getting their sea
legs and she was very tolerant Fox News
contributor you can read her column at
the Washington Times every Thursday I
believe I have that right Monica Crowley
thank you so much hey Steven always
great to be with you well come on let's
not lay it on too thick right right yes
there is no human who has accomplished
more than me we had to move this a bunch
of time so you were saying you just did
why is your schedule so hairy right now
is it because of the debates and all the
whole controversy with Fox News and
Trump what is it
well you know it's funny every August
you think August it's going to be sort
of calm and relaxing and and less
stressed than the rest of the year and
it's so not true right number World War
one started in August the guns of August
Saddam Hussein invaded Kuwait on August
2nd
things happen in August and this year
we've had very interesting domestic
developments heavenly with the rise of
Donald Trump and the debate and the
controversies and I think some of the
behind-the-scenes shenanigans happening
on the Democratic side with Hillary
Obama and the Democratic race so there
are a lot of things that are keeping me
running this is true ok so right off the
bat I know you you've you're pretty
even-handed but people always want to
take one sound bite are you a Trump fan
is that your guy or are you waiting to
see it all play out i I would put it
this way I have been giving Donald Trump
the benefit of the doubt I wouldn't say
I'm a Trump fan or supporter per se but
I think that he has tucked into
something really important here he's
giving voice to I think what remains of
the tea party normal Americans who just
want to take their country back and make
America great again his slogan it's
simple but it's powerful and Trump who
is a fighter who is an extremely
successful businessman so his last name
Trump is shorthand for
American dream who also gives off a
blue-collar vibe even though he's worth
ten billion dollars I think there's so
many things that have gone into the
Trump phenomenon that if the other
candidates were intelligent and that's a
big if they would be taking notes they'd
be paying close attention to not Donald
Trump style per se or the fact he wears
the trucker hat he does all these things
that are you know wild right but but pay
close attention to what he is conveying
out there that is gaining him so much
traction yeah um it's funny you
mentioned the blue collar oh I've always
sort of felt that way said Fox News you
have these hosts making these huge
salaries and they're looking out for the
folks like you haven't met a fokin for
years I have not had that I mean I could
walk away from the table forever if he
had Trump's kind of money he did file
Chapter eleven four times and then said
he didn't file personal bankruptcy
here's my issue with the Trump link
first off I'm not a Trump guy I'm not
convinced right this is just my personal
opinion nothing to do with we're going
to go with this when you have the
Clintons sit front and center at your
wedding when you support an abortion
when you were pro-gun get /a genius
moment for me is what I'm waiting for
I'm not saying I couldn't possibly be
convinced to go Trump but you know if
someone invents something right there's
actually a great film about this called
flash of genius they can pin down to
everyone who's either invented something
or had some great epiphany what they
call the flash of genius moment where
they say when did you hit this point in
your life when did you create this idea
and I was waiting for that from Trump on
the one he became conservative why when
he became a Republican and we didn't
really get it so that was for me with
that but there is a really weird shake
out and I know you have to be careful
because you work there but you guys must
feel the grass roots that have frankly a
lot of them have turned on Fox News with
the megyn kelly Trump thing a lot of
them are really irritated well what's
that like still being and under the Fox
umbrella as that's going down yeah I
mean I think a lot of it is calmed down
since it first broke on Friday and going
into the weekend I think a lot of calls
down but I think a lot of the Fox
audience is the tea party crowd it is
you know normal Americans in middle
America who have nowhere to go in the
media
at FoxNews and come on Fox News not to
carry the water of the conservative
movement but to at least be fair okay
all these years Fox has and I think the
impression out there fair or not was
that some of the questions for Trump
about going bankrupt about the women's
issues and everything else were unfair
because they weren't focused on the
issues the other candidates got issues
oriented question on Isis on reforming
Social Security on dealing with Iran and
and Trump was was fending off these
questions that were personal in nature
now you can say listen if you're running
for president you have to take all
comers you have to be willing to answer
every question and I totally agree with
that I'm just saying that that I think
for a lot of viewers Trump looked like
he was being singled out for attack on
things that were not related to issues
that most Americans really care about
right I understand where you're coming
from and I understand where they're
coming from but I think it's you know
we've always talked about this I even
have a stand-up bit about this how no
one is going to be able to run for
president and a couple of decades
because all of them have had a Facebook
account they've all been on message
boards really you want to run for
president sweet cherry 69 at yahoo.com
did you know in fact right that this
fart montage was of epic win on the I
mean you know there's no way it can
happen we're kind of hitting the first
time we've seen a reality show president
the reality TV you know what I I think
that's true but I think running for
president has been American Idol for a
long time your opponent since the advent
of television when my old boss had the
first televised debate in 1960 against
JFK Nixon versus JFK it is all image
it's charisma it's its enthusiasm it's
right but my point was my point was the
questions I feel if it felt like they
were singling out trumpets because he's
been so out there in the public I mean
that's how he's made most of his money
right he really became more successful
as a business person after apprentice
took off and that allowed him to
leverage it and I'm not begrudging him
at all but that's a big part of what
makes up the the Trump brand not so much
with say a Cruz or a Fiorina or maybe a
ben Carson so
wouldn't it be incredibly fair to ask
that since that's how he's made so many
of his bones look every question to me
if you're running for president you
better be prepared for all of it right
III make no excuses for any question you
get a question you know how to answer it
or at least should at that level take
Donald Trump the persona out of it for a
second and I know that's hard because
he's such a big personality but I've
identified three things even of what he
is doing it's saying the subtext of what
he is doing out there that I think are
critical apart from him the first is
that the American people are sick and
tired of being called the enemy in their
own country
if you don't agree with the leftist
agenda you're racist sexist homophobic
llama soap a bigot you know this better
than anybody because you write and do
things about this all the time see
America people are saying we don't know
we're not the enemy in our own country
we have actual enemies who are here and
abroad we're not it Trump champions
America any champions Americans anything
no you guys aren't the enemy that's
number one number two his catchphrase
you're fired
that is the subtext of everything is
doing and saying out there because it's
at the GOP establishment you're fired
the lamestream media you're fired it's
to the left it's in the White House and
and running the country right now you're
fired
that's a very powerful thing as well the
second thing is he has literally stated
the most important the most important
statement in this entire campaign when
he said I'm rich I'm really rich because
after decades and certainly in the last
seven years of the wealthy being
demonized and achievement being
demonized he goes out there unlike Mitt
Romney and has unapologetically said
yeah I'm rich and I embrace it and you
know what I wanted America where
everybody can make ten billion dollars
I'm telling you Steven that is an
incredibly powerful poll so you can say
what you want about Trump and and
although he's a clown II wherever and
try to dismiss him oh I'm the clown
mention but pay close attention to those
three things because they're incredibly
powerful polls of the voters I think
they are I think a big part of it I
think like you said he's a symptom
he's a symptom right now something the
Republican Party has created and I get
that they're upset and that's why listen
I understand why again I understand we
have to be careful since you I
understand why a lot of people are upset
with Fox News I think they see it you
know listen it's no secret that cable
isn't really doing that well for anybody
and I think they've seen it go a little
bit more centrist or appear that way and
they feel like Fox News has been pushing
Jeb Bush now having worked there I know
they don't have a secret meeting behind
anyone's back and say we're pushing Jeb
see but they feel that way and so they
see Fox now is more of an establishment
kind of centrist Republican Network and
they see them trying to necess
so I can understand why people feel that
way I think he's a symptom of people who
are really tired of the status quo with
politics now that being said I find it
ironic that what's sort of you know in
order to attack what they see is a
centrist sort of semi liberal network
now which is absurd they've needed a
full-on card-carrying Democrat until
2008 and Donald Trump to do it so I
understand the dialogue that needs to
take place I just think it's taking
place for all the wrong reasons right
now and not a lot it's not being very
productive but the kelie Trump thing
just seemed to me like it was incredibly
unproductive is that just me no I agree
I think it was a big distraction I think
it wasted a lot of time on all fronts
things happen you get that you get these
and I mean we're all on Twitter right
you get these little flash points you
get these dust storms that happen and
sort of consume everybody for a day or
two days or a couple of days and then
they die down and go away and you're on
to the next dust storm that's what I
think that was but set apart again the
specifics of Trump and what just
happened there sure they want a fighter
show me somebody's going to push back
when Trump said hey if the black lives
matter folks try to try to step on me
and take my podium on my mic I'm
fighting back that's the kind of thing
people want to see you mentioned Jeb
Bush Jeb Bush you could physically see
him recede on that stage that night
Scott Walker to God love him I mean I I
admire Walker so much and he could he
could go all the way Walker there so
low-key they don't show any energy
voters now are like oh my god okay so
we've been through the wars of Bush and
now we've been through the wars if Obama
were exhausted we want somebody to do
the fighting for us and that's why Trump
is captain today I like him or not agree
whether or not he's gonna have to flush
out his positions on all these issues I
I'm totally working on that but it's the
bigger vibe he's putting out there he is
finally standing up for the country
but do you think that maybe do you think
considering how inconsistent he's been I
mean just what woefully so do you think
that maybe he understands what you're
talking about from a business sense and
is using it to help Trump as opposed to
maybe actually really trying to
spearhead a new conservative movement
I'm not saying that's the case but
wouldn't that be a valid criticism
considering he's been so I mean he has
yet to really attack Hillary Clinton
certainly not like Fiorina or someone
like no I disagree with you he's the
only one out there calling her criminal
I know I said look they've all attacked
Hillary in different ways Carly Fiorina
said that she has lied about Benghazi
lied about the server and now we've got
the FBI and launching a full-on
investigation they have been criticizing
her but I think Trump goes right out
there and literally called her a
criminal I basically said she should be
in jail look Donald Trump I don't know
whether he's got the the fire in the
belly did it go all the way or or you
know can keep from really stepping in it
going all the way but what I do see is
Lehman is a real change in the dynamic
out there where you think we don't know
if he's a conservative he's been
Democrat before he's given to Democrats
all that is true and as a conservative I
don't necessarily trust his instincts I
mean he said he would fund partially
Planned Parenthood okay I got a big
problem with that yeah but I also think
that a lot of people don't care I think
a lot of people are like you know I
don't care I just want somebody who's
gonna fight for me yeah I don't think
you will I think the fights for Trump
that's my issue I don't think you'll
fight it not well but I know him a
little bit and I know he loves this
country body and soul you see that's the
issue and I think that's the issue and I
don't say it's because sweetheart I love
you but I think that's the issue people
have with media as people sing well
because I know Trump because I know
listen
we know that half of these candidates
are golfing buddies with executives at
Fox okay let's just be real here I think
that's a big part of what people don't
like and they feel like Trump is
exposing it a little bit you know when
he says he buys off politicians I'm
proud of it he exposed but the fact is
he's expected any time you see someone
exposed something you know that's
working in media often they're exposing
something so that they're hiding
something else in trouble he talked
about his cozy relationships with people
over there at maybe Fox News at CNN and
we all know he has them you know him
personally but of course I know you to
be an ethical journalist I don't know
that everyone on either side is we have
to go to break and I want to bring you
back because I like what you have to say
I dig it Monica Crowley louder with
Crowder's stay tuned we are back with
Fox News contributor Washington Times
columnist you can read them Thursdays
and also follow her on Twitter monica
crowley thanks for being back all right
I hear where you're coming from a Trump
and I agree with you in a lot I think
the issue we're kind of getting in a
Sarah Palin territory where there's no
room for an in-between for a critical
look either people are all in for Trump
and I mean if I say anything about Trump
the tweets are so you love Bush and you
think Obama than a great job I've been
critical of Jeb for a long time I'm not
a fan of him I don't even know if I'd
vote if it were Jeb Bush frankly I
honestly don't do you feel like we've
hit that ground like Sarah Palin where
either everyone is all-in or people
can't stand them there's no room for
in-between I'm not sure I'm not sure I'd
go that far I do see the emotional
reactions to Trump and and certainly
when this whole thing came down another
weird dynamic happened where you had a
lot of women including black women
defending Trump and pushing back on
megyn kelly and saying leave Trump alone
kind of thing but like that old Britney
Spears oh yeah those two were hilarious
yeah leave Britney Alone you know leave
Donald Trump alone Chris Rock yeah
meanwhile Hillary Clinton was defending
back in Cali so there are very weird
dynamics and weird bedfellows going on
here and people do feel emotionally
invested in this race because I think a
lot of voters feel like this is the last
chance you know we've been saying this
for a couple election cycles now but I
think probably this one is it because if
you don't have a a conservative in there
even a Republican I mean Jeb to me
it's the worst possible candidate you
can put up but if he's the nominee I
will vote for him because this is last
chance station if you don't repeal and
reverse pretty much everything Obama has
done then the country is gone well
that's a bird example right there right
a pivotal issue is the Affordable Care
Act Obamacare as call it Trump's the
only one on that stage you
unapologetically said that he thought
single-payer socialized health care
works great in Canada then he
regurgitated some old tired talking a
point from Republican Party about across
state lines but the fact remains he
genuinely thinks that single-payer
socialized health care is a good thing
in several countries and he hasn't
walked that back being from Canada I'm
going we're talking about him making a
menstruation maybe joke about megyn
kelly when he just supported socialized
health care said it worked that is such
a deal-breaker to me I'm amazed nobody
else is really talking about it yeah I
know
again I think at this early stage people
don't care much they will okay that will
turn you know when people start to get
really serious about casting their vote
people are invested in their votes it's
like spending money your vote is like a
hundred dollar bill you know you're not
going to just lay it down willy-nilly
you're gonna know what you're buying
here so I think that will change but as
of right now people don't really care
and that's hypocrisy and that's
hypocrisy and that's why and that's why
I don't do any media outside of my own
anymore I genuinely feel like the
conservative base can be just as easily
manipulated as the leftist base right
now when they made the whole thing about
Obama care bumper stickers everywhere
nobama care all this stuff all the silly
nicknames right and I was the first I
was at a tea party spoke at the very
first tea party with Michelle Malkin I
was a supporter of it I would
necessarily consider myself a part of it
but when Obamacare that's the biggest
issue and then they say well now we
don't care if Donald Trump supports even
more liberal health care than Barack
Obama that to me shows an inconsistency
if I think a contingency of people who
frankly are being manipulated I said I
think you're thinking too much about
this right now I don't think I think you
really I think they're not responding to
issue positions yet they're gonna have
one day to fight and that will that will
become it become clear and then people
will take second look
other candidates and it will wash out
the way it's supposed to wash out but
what I'm saying is right now they're
responding to something else it's not
that they're being bought I mean you
know the Tea Party crowd I do have
spoken at tea party these are normal
Americans who wants somebody who's
actually going to stand up and fight Ted
Cruz has stood up on Obamacare and
thought and took all the slings and
arrows from his own side his own
leadership the media the left the
Democrats I mean you name it and he's
still standing I think Ted Cruz is
actually very smart to hang out in the
draft of Donald Trump and be the only
one not critical of him because the more
tile on shrubs the more his numbers grow
up people feel like they want to defend
him but Cruz has been very smart II
think no this is foolish
he attention to what he's creating out
there and what he's tapping into I think
Cruz is actually handling this it's the
smartest way because he actually is the
fighter along with Scott Walker they've
proven records of standing up to the
left and fighting back that's what
voters want and I think once the Trump
phenomenon becomes less of a novelty and
more of like a standard-issue thing in
the campaign then Cruz and Walker I
think will be the beneficiary I think
that's what the Republican primary
voters want I think when it comes to a
general people want someone who they
feel is strong in leadership and as an
effective communicator and and that's
the issue I think Ted Cruz is going to
have he despite and I love the guy I've
known Ted Cruz my family lives in Texas
for a long time when he was you know
getting started I know the people who
work with him I just can't get past the
mr. Rogers delivery that people when you
look at national polls feel is a little
disingenuous so I think we need to
separate maybe right now what is
necessary for these primaries and I
think Trump is tapping into something
versus who's going to beat Hillary
Clinton and I think that narrows the
feel a little bit I think listen there
are a lot of things with which I
disagree with her as a matter of fact
you know who I think was handling this
really well was Carly Fiorina until the
megyn kelly thing I would have gone a
different angle as a woman with that
because there is such a large
contingency of people who are so tired
with feminism that I think they just
rejected and went after megyn kelly
period because they're tired of anyone
playing those cards and I think she
waded into that a little bit Carly and I
think she would've been better to attack
Trump's
manhood because then you'd see him fly
off the handle and yell all kinds of
misogynistic epithets where he would he
would be off the rails but um you know
imagine if someone just came out and
said well if Donald Trump can't handle
these kinds of questions from megyn
kelly i guess i carly fiorina
am more of a man than Donald Trump to
run for president blah blah blah you
know that would happen and I would pay a
nickel to watch that wrestling match at
at raw I agree with you they're not
attacking Trump doesn't serve any
purpose Perry might have killed his
chances doing that it just doesn't look
good for anyone right now you know if
you say something about Trump we can
notice that with the website we can't
post all-pro Trump stuff because I'm not
huge in trumpet if we post anything
critical people just say you're a rhino
and they turn on you why do you think
Cruz is the only one who sees that well
I you know he's a brilliant guy so I
think he understands what's going on
here he's also totally plugged into the
conservative base to see party the
evangelicals and he he knows what
they're thinking everything that I'd
laid out to you earlier in this
interview about being turned into the
enemy in their own country and and
wanting to fire the GOP leadership and
the media and the left and the Democrat
all the things that that Trump is giving
voice to Cruz understands and Cruz has
been doing it this whole time so I think
what he knows is look Donald Trump it's
not somebody who's going to be pushed
out of this race one second hold that
thought we have to do this break you
know these damn commercial breaks keep
the lights on Monica Crowley brilliant
also an attractive blonde who works at
fox news stay tuned to her she has to
leave soon so Monica Crowley Fox News
contributor is here Monica sorry to take
up so much of your time okay you wanted
to finish the thought you were making
about Trump commercials this is what
people have sorry I spaced
oh I think what I was saying was about
Ted Cruz sort of maximizing what what
Trump is onto here and I think that the
others basically should get out of the
way let Trump make the path for them but
understand what he's doing here and back
off the criticism leave the guy alone
like that Britney Spears did you thing
yeah and it will it will rebound a
masculine now did you know
that Chris Crocker he way he was like :
looked like a woman and now he's gone
back to looking like a guy and he's he's
I guess sort of yeah well not
gender-fluid
he's sexual orientation fluid oh by the
way I know what I wanted to say now your
gender fluid you know I'm not I'm
definitely a girl you mentioned Hillary
Clinton running against Hillary she's
not going to be the nominee
maybe Sanders I know I wrote a column
two weeks ago saying that what is
happening here is that Barack Obama is
taking Hillary Clinton out and I
recommend my column to everybody in The
Washington Times I ran two weeks ago
it's no bother taking Hillary out and
what is happening now with this DOJ
investigation the FBI now serving
seizing her server and her emails and
the thumb drive that investigation would
not be going forward if Barack Obama
didn't want it to go forward as we know
from the IRS investigation the DEA
investigation Obama stops anything that
he doesn't want moving forward he wants
this investigation he loathes the
Clintons he wants her out because he
needs a successor who will give him a
third term he needs somebody he can
control and no it's not Bernie Sanders
it's Joe Biden I lay out the entire
scenario around how Barack Obama's taken
around he's doing her in and he is going
to support his own vice president giving
him the full weight of the White House
all of the technical infrastructure that
they used in a wait and twelve the
social media and all the rest of it
Hillary Clinton has been begging for
that for seven years he refused to turn
it over to her and now we know why
there's sent a little bit fluoride in
the tap conspiracy theories but I think
you're right I do I think it's actually
probably a good read I don't know that
it'll necessarily work though I don't
know that Biden I tell you what though
if the nominees become Donald Trump and
Joseph Biden as a comedian there is
nothing that I would want more than that
I mean don't give you I think our
country would go to hell in a handbasket
I think would be such a fun debate to
watch I can't even get my head around it
gosh
that may be VPS it would be like Bernie
Sanders versus Fiorina
I would just oh I would murder me you
know what the dirt I know would be so
delicious
but you know what the Democratic ticket
is gonna be it's gonna be Joe Biden
because Obama's gonna back Biden and
he's gonna make it clear to minority
voters that Biden is his guy so he will
get the black vote the Latino vote and
everything they will follow Obama's lead
yeah had the vice president because if
they socialized Hillary with with an
indictment or a special prosecutor
whatever they're going to do they're
going to need to make it up to women so
it's going to be Elizabeth Warren Warren
ticket Elizabeth Warren makes it up to
women and she makes it up to the far
left mark my words you heard it here
first on ticket will be Biden Warren I
was going to say Satan but I guess the
two are interchangeable I feel like I
feel like Warren has Satan on the red
the red devil phone you know just sends
out the Satan signal this guy like
there's a baby let's kill it
yes exactly Elizabeth Warren Josh and I
all used to get her messed up with with
just in my brain of Debbie
wasserman-schultz
and I know they look nothing alike but
so many of their stories were so
interchangeable for a while were in my
head a goat now which which cackling
shrill evil broad said this go through
my mental rolodex Elizabeth Warren gosh
that would be a ruff ruff for years if
it were Biden and Elizabeth Warren and
you know she would have just his gonads
in a vice there's no way he'd be making
actual decisions if she's on there she's
wearing those pants don't you think
absolutely although remember Barack
Obama for years just said oh I can win a
center third term and he just started a
couple weeks ago again that is a very
revealing tell whenever he says that he
needs a third term and obviously can't
run although he shredded the
Constitution in every other way right uh
he means somebody he can control and he
knows that he can control button Biden
will be a handmaiden to Barack Obama
he'll do whatever you know he's not
going to reverse anything he's not going
to sing to his own playbook he will sing
according to the Obama playbook and
Obama knows that I think that's a good I
don't think it
necessarily wrong for Barack Obama to
think he could win a third term though
as much as it pains me to say it
III do think if he were able to run the
guy is so good at campaigning and
everything is in such disarray right now
I wouldn't be surprised if he were to I
know I know that sounds sacrilegious I'm
not saying I'd like it I don't think
he's entirely wrong in that statement am
I out of line no no I mean look if he
could do it if he could pull it off and
and like I said he's ravaged the
Constitution in every way possible
before then so if he thought he could do
it he would he would if that would of
course they're annoyed Bill Clinton who
has been agitating for change in the
22nd amendment so he could run for a
third term right oh yeah that's right
gosh well I mean if Hillary goes in it
might as well I I don't know I don't
really know a lot of people thought he
would be pulling the strings with
Hillary I think it was more so she was
pulling the strings with him back then I
mean not only is she obviously by the
way I'm not entirely convinced that
Hillary Clinton is interested in men
just so Monica Crowley didn't say just
for the record I would not be let's be
honest here no one would be surprised
right if Hillary Clinton were done with
her political career and it came out
that she had some secret lover named
Ethel we don't go yeah sure doesn't
surprise us she clearly wasn't
interested in her husband and he was
clearly a marriage of convenience I
don't think anybody would be surprised
just like I don't think anyone would be
surprised if Al Gore's the the masseuses
he was turning out to turned out to be
men but I do think that Hillary Clinton
was pulling the strings more so with
Bill and it's because she had so much
leverage on him with not just a low win
ski thing people forget that it was
borderline sexual aggravated sexual
assault with the other women who came
forward and Hillary knew about it so you
don't think she was able to get her way
I mean my wife you know can get her way
with me if I forget to do the dishes or
something because I'll feel bad and I
want to make sure that you know I had
police her later on you don't think
Hillary Clinton has the kind of leverage
where he can make him do whatever she
wants when she knows oh oh absolutely
and I think that's why he gave her the
whole health care portfolio in 1994 it
was like to placate her get her out of
his hair you know go into your thing
this is a major policy initiative go and
do it oh yeah oh absolutely yeah he's
really a vegan do you think Bill Clinton
is really a vegan now I yeah because he
looks kind of frail and pay off
I don't think you I know you have to go
see let me ask you this though last time
Koli I'm on politically related last
time I saw you were wearing those those
those those shoes those fitness shoes
those like Skechers he's still doing
that deal
I love Skechers yeah I have their
sneakers their walking shoes and their
flat though that shoe that was like the
big trend it was I can exit it was
supposed to work out your your oh yeah
the but right but then there was a
lawsuit against get your saying it was
an unverifiable claim so they had to
take it away but I have to say my butt's
looking pretty fierce so I think it
might be working good for you but how
dare you how dare you play the butt card
as a woman and then you know you're
gonna get the backlash with the megyn
kelly thing that was the now you do
Kelly show very often I know you did
Bill show so I know I have to be careful
with this do you do her show very often
once in a while once in a while yeah I'm
not I'm not a huge fan because after I
left Fox News there's some guy and I
said across from her many times there
some guy did some online video that's
what the problem with media now is no
one can play nice with each other but
the one thing is I think it was an
appropriate question do you think it
might have been better played for her to
come out and speak against the people
kind of playing the delicate flower
she's a woman Trump was out of line
because it seemed like a lot of people
were saying listen she's a strong woman
why doesn't she handle herself with this
there just seemed to be an awkward
silence when that was going on is there
something we don't know about
well Megan Kelly's a good girl she's
tough as nails
so not really worried about her I
actually focus more on Donald Trump and
I think the way he should have answered
that question was you know what Megan
first of all I can't remember any of
those quotes secondly if they are
attributable to me I'd like hear the
whole context because we know about the
one about a woman on her knees was taken
completely out of context begging him
for a job not you know sexual sexually
servicing him the ended third point I
would say was I would looked at her and
said Megan if you want to talk about the
mistreatment of women I'm happy to talk
about Isis selling women into sex
slavery or the Taliban shooting Malala
in the head because she demanded
education any of those issues I'm happy
to talk about why don't you run for
office would you vote for me
yes I'd but while I vote for you on the
but alone according to you well yeah
they get rid of Kim Kardashian she's she
was there for a while if she still
that's a good point but do you okay last
question will let you go obviously
people are talking about this when he
said or whatever do you think it was a
menstrual joke or do you think he's
juice just wasn't sharp enough to go
through his mental rolodex and say um
nose look I don't know all I know is
when I'm on a you know radio or
television or something your mind is
working so fast especially in a pressure
cooker like a debate or you know on a
television interview I you know given
what I know about Donald Trump I do not
think he would be that crass so I
actually think he was like in the middle
of a thought and then jump to the next
thought and it came out that way I do
not think I actually take his
explanation at face value I don't think
he was going there I think he meant you
know knows I don't work force of her
head you know bleeding out of the head
and that kind of thing just get him the
kindergarten get him the kindergarten
songbook head and shoulders knees and
toes eyes ears mouth and nose I wanna I
want our president to at least be able
to go through a preschool nursery rhyme
rolodex of words so that he can pick the
right one so either way isn't that a
little bit of an issue no but I also
think again I keep getting back to you I
think a lot of voters look at him and go
he's a little bit of an a-hole a little
bit of a jerk but you know what that
could make him a really great president
no I think well worded very clever we
tried to get the the the the the back
the back talk out of Monica Crowley and
classy as always read her columns
Washington Times every Thursday right
Monica yeah every Thursday Washington
Times calm I've got an interview with
Carly Fiorina this week oh well we had
our last week so tell her I say hello
and I'm interested to see what she does
and we'll have you back to them with
Skype because everyone wants to see your
you know everybody come on that's a big
selling point I I know I know I can't
even turn on my TV but okay we will we
will work on skype
I'll make you make you walk me through
installing it and getting it up and
running okay thank you so much Monica
ladder with Browder stay tuned if you'd
like this video subscribe by clicking my
face or watch one of these videos next
to me or go to ladder with greater comm
for a bunch of stuff that you can't find
on youtube if you don't the next video
will be me and lingerie doing stuff
weird stuff and I don't mean the kind of
weird stuff that's FCC okay when you
pitch it to writers and say is this
weird enough but kind of weird okay for
TV I'm talking internet dark corner
weird stuff